nous allons rejoindre neauphle le
château et nous accueillons ce soir pour
parler des médiévales de
neauphle-le-château donc ces deux
journées de festivités autour la
thématique du médiéval donc déjà jacques
garros ainsi que jean-michel terrain
tirant pardon alors vous êtes tous les
deux présidents alors à des dates
différentes
voilà donc vous jacques voulez vous
l'étiez en 2011 et 2012 soient là et
vous jean michel vous serez à compter
d'août à juin
voilà alors président de quoi et bien du
lion ce club de neauphle-le-château donc
qui organise ces journées médiévales
alors j'ai déjà envie de vous demander
donc c'est un festival comme on l'a dit
autour de la thématique médiévale
comment est née cette idée peut-être
jacky mais que des c'est surprenant mais
nous sommes un club de 26 membres et un
jour en prenant un café à neauphle le
château avec certains amis ils m'ont
laissé entendre que les activités que
faisait le club était un petit peu
ancienne entre guillemets chadi
m'attendais c'est facile de critiquer
vous venez d'entrer au club proposer
quelque chose
pas de pot une semaine après ils m'ont
dit viens voir et nous en dissuader les
fêtes médiévales de neauphle-le-château
ça va bien n'ouvre le château souffle en
effet historiquement à
une histoire pour du médiéval tout à
fait ses calculs inondant la juste une
idée comme ça at il ment mais j'ai eu un
petit peu peur au départ et puis
progressivement nous avons démarré nous
nous sommes à la quatrième année et tout
se passe à priori très bien parce que
les gens sont très contents alors 4e
année est-ce que du coup vous avez
continué dans ce renouveau et on a des
activités banon nouvelle pour pour cette
quatrième édition est bien effectivement
donc nous attaquons la quatrième année
nous travaillons déjà sur une prochaine
et nous avons fait venir cette année des
troupes nouvelles vues par exemple un
très grand drakkar de douzièmes de l'eau
qu'il y présentera la vie des vikings à
cette époque là donc ce sera plutôt à
terme de l'exposition et de
participation à ce qui se passe dans le
drakkar lui la traque à un stade ou
devant la salle de l'île de la maison du
jeu de paume qui la salle que les auprès
de la mairie
je dois dire que la mairie de nos
fleuves est un excellent partenaire dans
nos opérations médiévale et ne donne un
intrépide demain non à part cela depuis
depuis plusieurs années nous organisons
des tournois de chevalerie
peut-être je peux l'expliquer je compte
au niveau des nouvelles troupes us est
la troupe déterra chrome ce sont des
bâtisseurs de cathédrales qui vont
expliquer aux jeunes et et aux moins
jeunes dans nos façons parti maintenant
comment à l'époque on
c'est pour hisser en haut du cathédrale
des pierres qui pesait des centaines
voire peut-être des plus jeunes en fait
il va y avoir un côté explicative doit
s'aimer tad s'est passé bien orienté
familiale notre fête donc les parents
viennent avec les enfants et la plus
belle récompense que j'ai eu là un
dernier en tant que président c'est
quand une petite fille à la sortie de la
fête a marqué sur le livre d'or je me
serais plus là d'humour exact mais j'ai
plus appris en une journée
chez les chez toi ou chez vous je me
suis plus qu'à l'école en u en une année
j'aimerais que ceux des miséreux comme
tout mais peut-être que ça va vous
donner des idées pour vous impliquer sur
les prochaines années avec cette réforme
du temps scolaire ça laissera du temps
libre pourquoi pas pour organiser les
médiévales leur fallait faire partie
s'est faite autour d'eux et tout au
furet et bien voilà c'est une idée que
je vous soumets vous voyez une merci au
site s'est pas dissipé ses frères faut
noter que c'est une grosse grosse
organisation vous faites appel à des
professionnels
on aura des troupes de danse de musique
non mais une quinzaine de troupes qui
représente un peu plus de 90 personnes
quand même à nourrir loger certains
parce que les rats qui vont à l'hôtel
nos trucs qu'il faut qu'ils dorment sous
leurs tentes dans leur campement etc
j'allais dire grandiose mais je crois
que le mot n'est pas trop fort on a fait
quelques quelques photos dans une
édition précédente
oui on voit qu'elles aient les moyens
vraiment sont déployés pour donner à ces
deux journées vraiment un écho important
c'est d'en créer une ambiance
particulière justement dans la commune
de voyager comme ça à travers le temps
absolument vous pouvez pas imaginer les
yeux des enfants qui arrivent et qui
voit ça le seul reproche qu'on ait eue
en trois ans c'est le bruit du canon qui
était a priori trop fort ton certains
petits curieux un petit peu peur donc
personne n'y avait pensé mais les joutes
équestres
alors justement on va on n'y a pas ce
que tu as des activités nouvelles et
puis à des choses qui fonctionne chaque
année donc vous re proposer en
l'occurrence donc un tournoi de lens
c'est sa loi de la loi
à charge en battue alors de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit donc de preux chevalier tout
cas pas tout car a pas sonné lourdement
car un passionné qui des joutes
équestres ce sont des joutes équestres
et qui vont donc dans un grand dans un
grand pré comme au moyen-age
s'affrontaient d'accord et cette année
la particularité si je suis mise à mort
non non mais ce qui est étonnant c'est
que la france va rencontrer l'amérique
alors l'amérique c'est parce que c'est
le canada + et états unis c'est ça qu'on
m'a dit l'amérique parce que les usa
n'existait pas bien sûr certains
internationaux c'est un tournoi
international
nous avons des gens comme marek qui est
un polonais qui vient qui est un fana de
ces compétitions équestres
l'année dernière nous avions un
américain qui est venu avec son armure
qui coûte la bagatelle de 50 mille
dollars
ce qui est marrant parce que les états
unis ont clairement c'est pas leur
période
vous avez raison mais les gens
commencent de plus en plus apparemment
est partout à s'intéresser à racines
lointaines à nos racines lointaines et
alors
l'année dernière combien de personnes
combien de visiteurs avec vos reçus tout
avait ni d un petit peu moins de dix
mille centres c'était entre cette ligne
la redescente énorme et objectifs cette
année cette année l'objectif c'est de
faire un petit peu mieux et on espère
arriver à 10000 et on espère avoir le
mot temps avec nous qu'on revient pas
dessus
on aura du beau temps mais je pense
qu'on aura effectivement les dieux
dizaines de milliers de participants
on l'a pas dit mais la possibilité et ça
c'est quand même quelque chose de
vraiment sympa je trouve de pouvoir
louer des costumes parce que le tout on
voyage dans le temps mais il faut aussi
revêtir les costumes d'époque
donc vous avez en l'occurrence l'atelier
ziane csat li jian qui viennent du
département 45 de verre chez jeanne
d'arc qui viennent louer des costumes
qui arrive vendredi en début d'après
midi et qui nous consentons un tarif
préférentiel dans son souhait de
facturer deux jours et nous facture
qu'un jour les enfants ils ont sorti des
prix très bas parce qu'on tenait à ce
que les enfants soient et on a une petit
stand qui s'appelle la petite armurerie
qui est un stand qui vont des clients en
bois des casques des trucs pour les
petites filles et c'est grâce à un
succès d'en faire ça donc la possibilité
de louer donc des costumes des alors
pour ceux qui veulent avoir le plus de
choix va céder vendredi après midi à 15
heures et puis sinon tout au long du
week end
alors donc voilà c'est ce que j'allais
dire parce que c'est pour donc dans le
cadre du lion's-club d'accord donc le
losc bora en amour vous pouvez nous dire
l'objectif de cette organisation
dans ce cas c'est une des plus grandes
ong du monde
quatre cent mille membres dans le monde
40 les en france et vous est vrai pour
des angines havre pour le bien de la
cité pour les maladies donc nous sommes
par exemple partenaire du téléthon
nous allons cette année travaillée pour
la rougeole qui est un fléau ne vaut pas
que papa bien connu mais qui très très
dangereux la sclérose en plaques et à
par exemple l'édition précédente conçu
pour lui dire peut-être une fourchette
du moins les bénéfices que vous avez
récolté ils ont été en dire combien et
c'est en direction de quoi en gros qu'un
seul un peu moins de seize mille euros
qui nous ont servi à idées localement et
un peu internationalement puisque par
exemple les ingénieurs les futurs
ingénieurs de l'école d'agroparistech de
plaisir grignon on les subventionnent
entre guillemets on les aide à réaliser
des placements voilà à financer des
déplacements au cameroun pour la lutte
contre la malaria
vous avez aussi perdre offert je crois
aux communes des déchets des
défibrillateurs à métaux et oui avez
tout essayé on a offert plusieurs
défibrillateurs à plusieurs communes
tentent à neauphle-le-château que dans
les environs et on continue si les
résultats sont toujours au rendez vous
et ce que je n'en doute pas un seul
instant vous amuserez vous permettrez à
une bonne cause donc de prospérer on va
rappeler l'année puis les tarifs
exactement donc c'est le 1er et le 2
juin devant la maison donc de la maison
à la maison du jeu de paume on and off
le château où tout est fléché tout est
fait ici alors on a commencé le fléchage
environ
de lyon n'ont peut-être pas si loin
qu'il met au niveau de la nationale 12
déjà tout est bien fléchir il ya un
droit d'entrée pour financer nos bonnes
oeuvres
c'est un droit d'entrée de 10 euros pour
les adultes pour les adultes et les
enfants jusqu'à 14 ans sur la grille et
voilà et on peut re préciser que sur
place on trouve restauration boissons et
tout est à disposition pour ceux qui
nous écoutent qui s'occupe d'enfants en
difficulté ou d'enfants handicapés
l'entrée est bien sûr gratuite très bien
merci bravo pour cette jolie opération